cBS reboot of Murphy Brown is one of
this fall's most highly anticipated
shows and picks up 20 years after the
finale the hit comedy first aired back
in 1988 starring Candice Bergen is a
tough-talking TV journalist actress
faith Ford played the perky TV reporter
named Corky Murphy Brown was considered
a groundbreaking show at the time
winning 18 Emmys over ten seasons it
portrayed a career focused independent
woman the way the series tackled
important issues like politics and
Family Values made a lasting impact on
our culture I'm surprised at you I would
have thought you would want the whole
natural childbirth experience
alright the unforgettable thrill of
passing a bowling ball oh boy sign me up
but this O'Shea guy takes the cake if I
wanted this kind of ridicule and abuse I
got a burger vice-president primetime TV
as Murphy Brown a character who
supposedly epitomizes today's
intelligent highly paid professional
woman mocking the importance of fathers
perhaps it's time for the vice president
to expand his definition and recognize
that whether by choice or circumstance
families come in all shapes and sizes
you're spending the day covering senator
Bricker will you be back in time for
your interview with James Baker
no problem brickers a politician up for
re-election what could his day entail
breakfast lie lie lunch lie lie
my fourth rocket is degrading
dehumanizing repulsive what are you
saying you don't want to do the
interview ooh you Harvard guys can't put
anything over on Candice Bergen and
faith board are here at the table good
morning good morning welcome welcome
welcome I am so excited about this
reboot because of course I remember
Murphy Brown but when you look at those
clips she seems very gentle compared to
what we see now she was ahead of her
time wasn't she Candice yeah she was as
it turns out yeah I don't think we
realize just quite how edgy was when she
was created Diane English wrote a woman
that we hadn't really seen on television
yet who was a woman totally
self-confident didn't care what other
people thought didn't nope no politeness
no groveling and 20 years later she's
still that girl yeah years later she's
still that girl you have seven in the
net but you've said if there wasn't the
election of Donald Trump you might not
have this show what do you mean oh we
definitely wouldn't have had the show
because really we we've done the show
and we've done it as well I think as it
had ever been done and we didn't have a
motivation to do it we didn't really
have the the meet or a story and then
when the election at but I mean if
Hillary had one we we would just be
dancing in the streets but I think in
the current situation it gives us a
chance to make a response but we should
say faith it's not a Donald Trump
bashing show either that's to be no it's
not it's really not it's we're staying
on point with issues I mean there really
are a lot of issues going on that we're
going on then mm-hmm and they're still
going on and we're dealing with them
every week and that's predominantly what
our show is about and you do offer
opinions on the certain issues though
and you see where you're headed and your
minds are are you concerned at all about
it abandoning viewers we are you I don't
want to
I have to say for all those people in
the middle of it I mean I speak for that
world because I live in Louisiana when
I'm not in New York I've sort of always
lived in the middle and I see myself
that way I understand both sides
I love Republicans as well as Democrats
in in real life and so I believe there's
a way for our country to get along no
matter what I think the divisive nests
from the top you know it really does
Candis what was it like was Murphy Brown
living in your head during those 20
years that you weren't on the show what
was it like to reconnect with that
character she wasn't actively you know
ransacking the house of my head but he
was never far away and she was by far
the best character I've ever gotten to
play and she was a great great character
she is a great Candace I must say now in
this she's so relaxed in this business
human being and you that's the way you
want somebody who's been in this
business in the news business to be you
know she's coming back but she's not
shrieking yes he's not shrill she
literally is so calm and present and
purposeful in her delivery I mean it's
just we talked about it just amazing and
she's still super smart one of the great
one of the interesting storylines cuz
you know when you had Avery back in the
day that was a scandal of sorts the
single woman having to sortie yeah that
was a that was a big scandal fast
forward to 2018 a second okay we're
throwing baby showers for single women
but now Avery your son is on a competing
morning show you guys have one morning
show Murphy in the morning Avery's on a
competing morning show called the wolf
Network conservative Network wolf and I
think that's gonna be some of the most
fun moments on the show what did what
was that like that dynamic between the
two of you oh I love working with Jake
Jake McDorman is is of course dashingly
handsome everybody on the set has a
crush on him but he's also he just
misses nothing and he has a great sense
of humor and so working with him is just
a joy hey what was it like coming back
for you today
show after such a long period away is it
like riding a bike
well you know we all sort of had to work
on our pacing a little bit because it
got very single-camera like with comedy
and it's sort of like no it's too jokey
no it's what's been relaxing about it is
that we're back to doing it the way it
used to be like where it's a play but
the difference is is that I guess we we
try to slow down a little bit I'm trying
to slow down because when I deliver
Corky I mean I immediately go to another
level
yeah whole nother level yeah and so it's
sort of finding that cadence right just
the right but we actually flow with each
other the the core and what was so great
for us is seeing the new characters like
Tyne Daly it's been yes and she just
that I can't even imagine that anybody
else had that bar I mean she's literally
gone in with her own character she has
all this under stuff that she plays all
the time I can't imagine anybody in any
of their roles I'm so glad you guys are
back and quirky by the way has hot
flashes I think Candice Berg at Candice
Bergen her name is not changed thank you
guys the new Murphy Brown premieres
tomorrow night at 9:30 8:00 central
right here on CBS the mothership
mothership mothership